failed gubernatorial candidate Kerry
Lake and uh Bonkers election denier
is clearly planning to run for Senate or
it's very likely that she's going to run
for Senate in Arizona
um I have a moment from a recent
interview for you here where she gets
asked about her 2024 plans and
we've seen her showing up in Iowa so
some people are thinking is she wanting
to be Trump's vice presidential running
mate which I'm sure she would
want that as well but it does seem her
eyes are set on a senate run
um take a look
at this
wow you thought it was going to be easy
I thought it was okay we're friends well
then I'll just be really honest which
one do you want to tackle the senate or
the VP one first let's hit them both
head on okay um obviously my case is is
the most important thing of course but
you're asking if things don't go well if
the judicial system is much more corrupt
than we than we think it is
what happens I am seriously considering
a run for Senate yes absolutely because
just because they sold an election we're
so dangerous to them I'm so dangerous to
the status quo and this rotten swamp
that they're willing to steal the
election to stop me and our movement I'm
not letting them get away with that
we're not going away and so you're
dangerous to democracy uh not dangerous
to the status quo and kind of a good way
of mixing things up and improving it
we'll watch a little bit more from this
but uh there
when politicians say I'm seriously
considering it that means it's
definitely happening because normally
the answer is oh I don't know I'm I'm
focused on only this I'm not even
thinking about that and still they like
clear considering if you say I'm really
seriously considering it that's
definitely uh the plan that you're
working on and again she's also
been seemingly auditioning to be Trump's
vice presidential running mate so maybe
she's waiting to see how that's gonna
work out but the bad part about this
um and we'll talk about another
important angle on this after the second
clip I'm going to show you but uh first
is because Christian Cinema seems to
also be running for reelection as an
independent but is still left of center
and Ruben Gallegos in the race if Carrie
Lake does get into the race or another
Republican but especially someone as
dangerous as Carrie Lake just with her
uh election and dying and conspiracy
theories and all that
she'll have a better shot because of the
independent Democratic split situation
in my mind and how that could mix things
up
um so it'll definitely be something we
watch closely But continuing with this
interview
I am seriously considering a run for
Senate all the polling shows that I
would win not just the primary the
polling is showing I would beat both
Kirsten Cinema and this socialist guy
that's running they're Democrats
and so what are you worried though
Carrie because we know and it depends on
the poll that you look at Ruben Gallego
has been leading both Carey Lake and
Christian Cinema in polling recently the
voter rolls are corrupt we know that
these mail-in ballots can be corrupted
all these issues with Maricopa County
specifically and obviously if you run
for that senate seat just like
gubernatorial that's the entire State
not like a congressional district of
only 700 000 folks you're running for
the whole state how do we guarantee do
we have new stuff in place will you have
new poll Watchers make sure it's not
screwed this is why I'm fighting it
right now I want to I want to get our
elections straightened out and I want
them to be honest and that's why I'm
fighting it so hard right now we'll take
it to the Supreme Court if we okay and
then she's talking about her election
soup but that is representative of this
strange logical
uh you know the the gymnastics that has
to be done mentally for supporters of
people like Trump and Kerry Lake because
now
uh Trump is and Kerry Lake May soon be
running another campaign
and convincing their followers that yeah
as I keep saying the last election was
stolen
and nothing significantly has changed
within my conspiracy theory about what
is going on all the corruption
but I could win this one in the case of
trump the Dominion voting system with
flipping thousands and thousands of
votes from Trump to Biden but that's not
going to happen in 2024.
I don't understand as a follower how you
don't
just disengage and not understand uh how
your vote is going to make a difference
if the Democrats have this big
conspiracy where they can steal
elections as uh Carey Lake says and
Trump says but the other
um
notable part about a possible 2024 uh
Carey Lake Senate run is how the
election denying will play into that
because
um for the General Electric obviously I
just talked about how it plays into her
own voters thinking it was stolen but
also thinking she could win it this one
but then how it plays into uh her
ability to win the general
election because we saw that not work
in 2022. now as I said with the unique
landscape with the independent that can
mix things up
but generally the midterms definitely
highlighted this
um
the American electorate wholesale is not
on board with uh the election tonight
and so for her to lean into that so much
and for her 2024 campaign to be similar
to trumps which is hey I lost that last
election but I don't think that I did is
a strange strategy and it really is as
you can tell in every interview she does
and all of her uh public statements it's
what she's obsessed with she can't
accept that she just lost so she has to
have like Trump the conspiracy theories
and so when that's a part of a campaign
I I just don't see how that works it
could unfortunately but reasonably I
don't see how that could work to say I
should be elected because I falsely
believe I lost the last or I actually
won the last time when I lost
um but that's the moment that we're in
in American politics make sure uh you
are subscribed to the Dave Pacman Show
YouTube channel and my YouTube channel
at Luke Beasley on YouTube
so great uh guest hosting today much
love to you all I'll see you soon